falls du noch ein bisschen Pizza übrig
hast zeige ich dir heute die beste
Methode um sie wieder warm zu bekommen
zwei Probleme der Boden ist weich und
oben ist trocken wie lösen wir das Ganze
in einer Pfanne die habe ich schon mal
warm werden lassen dort gebe ich jetzt
bei mittlerer Hitze die beiden Stücke
einfach hinein so geben wir den Boden
jetzt 30 40 Sekunden um wieder knusprig
zu werden versteht mich nicht falsch
kalte Pizza ist auch übertrieben nice
aber so kriegen wir sie wieder frisch
der Boden sollte wieder knusprig sein
jetzt gebe ich ein bisschen Wasser an
den Rand und schließe einen Deckel das
Wasser verdampft und befeuchtet die
Pizza wieder von oben zum Vergleich
wieder aufgewärmt und nicht wieder
aufgewärmt der Unterschied ist eindeutig
machen immer den Sound Test
[Musik]
also es gibt glaube ich keine Methode
mit dem man näher an eine frische Pizza
wieder daran kommt